the vast expanse of russia's arctic has
some powerful defenses to match
starting with the navy
in its class this military vessel is the
largest in the world
named after peter the great it is the
jewel in the crown of russia's
northern fleet it is its flagship in
it took part in russia's naval operation
anti-terror operation
off the coast of syria as threats evolve
so does russia's military and the
northern fleet is no exception
its ships are in a constant process of
modernization
we had hoped to fly even closer to the
north pole on the same day
but the arctic had other plans these are
unwelcoming lands we had to wait for
several days before taking this flight
just waiting for the weather to improve
but finally we're here
in this military cargo plane which is
taking us and all of our colleagues to a
russian
military base in the arctic
[Music]
this island and the france joseph
archipelago is home to russia's
northernmost military base in the arctic
and just
getting here is already a challenge just
check out the
conditions this military jet had to land
in
the runway is literally layers of ice
the base we're about to see is unmatched
it's the only
permanent construction in the world
operating
this far north this whole part of the
world is made up of snow
ice and rock and the only thing that has
sprouted here in the past decade or so
is
well this the arctic trefoil or the
arctic shamrock
this military base is completely
autonomous and a soldier
doesn't really have to leave its walls
to go around their daily business
which is pretty convenient when
temperatures here drop
in the minus 40 and -50 territories
and every single officer would ask to
elaborate as to
what what is it exactly that this
military base does
they would go well sorry no can do
because all of it is
quite top secret but not everything is
kept in the dark of course
the main purpose of the arctic trefoil
is air defense
in a region once deemed russia's most
vulnerable against
this type of attack at the same time on
the coast
the military has deployed some
formidable firepower to defend the
shores
against battleships this is russia's
bastion in the north well literally this
is
what these anti-vessel missile complexes
are called and
quite aptly too firing off the coast in
that
direction in the direction of the
icebergs over there
they can hit targets as far as 360
kilometers away
nato has lately stepped up at saber
rattling in the arctic
but russia does not shy away from baring
its teeth
right back at them amagushdhana
reporting from the arctic
for rt
you